boa noite meu nome ao seu dinheiro
sou tecnologia alimentar e faz como
vocês todos os dias tem que tomar
decisões têm que tomar decisões quando
vou comprar um produto alimentar
talvez questionaram e como é que
aparecem os produtos que encontro nas
ruas nas prateleiras dos mercados
quando você já ficaram na dúvida foi
comprado em algo natural minha obsessão
brain ao longo do sabor apurado seja
convidativo
talvez o caso mais conhecido e talvez
mais ainda mais amigo você jogava tudo
isso vamos comprar mais rigor como gordo
18 marca já se enfrentaram momentos
pensaram como é que isto é possível
passar nos centros de investigação nas
universidades nas empresas é conviver de
forma e de acordo com as necessidades
dos consumidores
e mesmo com toda essa inovação
muitos produtos são total e sucesso
nem todos os produtos é uma cidade muito
baixa consegue chegar à casa dos
consumidores e consegue realmente ser
comercializado mas para tentarmos evitar
esse sucesso tentamos saber quais são as
necessidades o que o consumidor quer que
ele fique com algumas dessas cidades a
questão do preço é muito importante
de sabor e gestão do espectro a
confiança é mais fácil a cozinhar 70 com
medo
são questões que durante muito tempo e
fizeram com conversa e inovação nos
produtos já têm mudado usados pelos
violentos que as sociedades consumidor
está a mudar e temos que nos adaptar aos
consumidores
questões como o aquecimento é a melhor
avaliação o que evitará por exemplo caso
cada
sex 1º alguns alimentos que têm são mais
de 15 também estamos
era mais ágil será que o alimento é
feita de forma sustentável
será que a embalagem biodegradável
será que os alimentos estavam de acordo
com a consumir tempo só conservados por
anos será que é natural
ainda para mais com a sua nova e não
aceitar novas geralmente da geração y
que quer produtos totalmente diferentes
produtos realmente que só com factos e
completamente diferente do que existe em
você comprar e consumir vários os
produtos têm surgido nos últimos anos
com base nesta análise que virão neste
ponto não quero a forma como é que as
empresas conseguem buscar informação ao
consumidor
as escolhas consumidor e criar de
aumento produtos de acordo com as suas
necessidades
temos alimentos com vitaminas fizemos
uma capital sem luta temos produtos
alimentares direcionados para neste caso
os consumidores a crianças para pessoas
mais velhas australianos alimentos que
são direcionados de acordo como o sexo
do consumidor se é um homem uma mulher
estamos a falar de alimentos energéticos
são vários os produtos que têm surgido
os últimos anos e que tenha parecido com
base no medo passar calma no e
crescimento aos novos ingredientes
considerados ingredientes causam
mudanças alguns processos que são
utilizados para desenvolver novos furos
no entanto novos desafios
espera se que em 2050 a população
mundial chega algumas pessoas
espera-se também estima se vamos ter que
duplicar os alimentos que existem a
nível mundial com a consciência da oscot
testamento com o passado e para que isso
aconteça vamos ter também que dois atos
menos 70% das tecnologias utilizadas
para a produção desse aumento tem que
ser mais eficientes sustentáveis forma
realmente conseguimos aumentar todas
essas pessoas têm uma forma sustentável
fica a questão é como é que nós podemos
fazer isto como é que nós podemos ir ao
encontro das necessidades dos
consumidores
como é que nós podemos entregar e dar ao
consumidor uma farinha que a única coisa
que eu quero é que foi uma estréia sem
isso em condições para ser consumida
traz além da distribuição uma embalagem
em condições ou vamos criar prêmios aos
consumidores querem uma farinha e seria
vitamina a com isenção de multa
são vários implementos temos do produtor
do agricultor
o agricultor com o trator foram criados
há pouco temos aqui estava do dodô
sabendo alimento temos a questão do
vendedor do roteirista todos os erros e
todos nós vamos ter que trabalhar em
conjunto para responder àquelas questões
primeira necessidade dos consumidores
cada vez criando produtos mais
diferenciados mais direcionados para
pagar aquilo que se espera e ao mesmo
tempo dar resposta à questão do aumento
da proporção a questão das tecnologias
mais vacinas o que nós engenheiros
aumentaram tecnólogos alimentares
queremos fazer o que nós propomos alguma
forma para ajudar nesta neste desafio
essa tentativa realmente sermos mais
eficientes na forma como trabalhamos na
forma como o governo fundamentos aos
consumidores o que eu proponho que
ocupamos engenharia reversa versa já é
muito conhecida e já muito conhecida
sobretudo nos nos dias de carne e
informática
nenhum está a aumentar realmente apesar
de já se falar há algum tempo e não está
a circular na linha versa trata de saber
os ingredientes dos complementos e o
processo no qual um produto é
desenvolvido e como é que nós consigamos
chegar àquela funcional irá trabalhar
com alimentos
estamos a trabalhar com estruturas com
uma matriz muito complexa passa por
diferentes processos podemos continuar
meus
quer ser o alimento temos que chegar a
altas temperaturas com o tempo poderemos
produzir nessa linha mas nós conseguimos
realmente o engenheiro meta desenvolver
produtos direcionados uma forma mais
eficiente dessa imagem muito complicado
como é que nós podemos fazer isso nós
temos que ter um processo de produção do
alimento até ao momento em que o
consumidor passa por cima e da forma
como é que vai ser
temos que pensar em todo este processo
chegar à estrutura e à propriedade de
uma forma inversa
qual é a propriedade funcional
a feira vai contar com um sistema de
sistemas tradicionais
conseguimos perceber se excluir o
consumidor é que nós criamos uma
estrutura no momento em que ela tinha e
depois o processo também o consumidor
vai ingerir via oral o alimento
a sessão vai ter a obsessão a textura o
prazer que aumenta também é importante
na alimentação não é só está um
profissional é que está só está passando
pela energia para viver nós chegaríamos
a questão do prazer também não seja
também temos que perceber como é que nós
conseguimos ter uma estrutura um
elemento realmento que tem as
características sensoriais para que o
corpo possui do estado espera e depois
temos que chegar ao processo em que
temos que saber também se esse elemento
consumidor com propostas contrário vai
ser sábado em casa a cozinhar só vai ser
consumido diretamente também aqui se
forçado podemos ter
as propriedades que vai ganhar nas
propriedades vai poder para depois ter a
questão sensorial e estado de estado e
não da forma convencer os amigos
garantia que nós conseguimos e no
momento em que o consumidor vai comprar
o momento conseguimos controlar as ações
da companhia estão embalagens questão do
rótulo muito importante hoje em dia pra
aquele que nós começamos a trabalhar e
eu conseguimos começar a desenvolver uma
estrutura assim envolver um movimento
que os conhecia realmente movimentar sua
maior escala micro escala ela ficava
temos que saber realmente como é que os
que não pode ser fixado economia
convencional que disputaram o sensor
nativos para conseguirmos grave ter um
alimento que depois cobrado do
consumidor todos os processos passa até
o seu consumo vai ser ingerido e vai se
ele vai se comportar na forma como nós
prevíamos e terem uma maior ou são
nutrientes um evento maior saúde também
não podemos assim grávida mas só
conseguiu uma forma um pouco mais
simples nós temos que conhecer a
estrutura a propriedade e funcionalidade
é estruturado num movimento
existem diferentes componentes
diferentes ingredientes podemos ter uma
linha mas vamos trabalhar com
conseqüente proteínas lipídeos temos que
saber realmente as suas grupos
funcionais seu peso é claro as suas
cargas vai constatar as coisas muito
esquisitas rural substituição e isto
vários lados realmente sem os
ingredientes são competitivas
realmente conseguimos fazer de fio e
entrou na área que ocorrem dentro de uma
linha com o nosso consumidor queira
nossas diferentes texturas diferentes
lugares negócios com o méxico no momento
como é o caso da água com esse tamanho
resistentes à falta de sistemas ou nada
e colocou que o pretendente é pra que
consigamos chegar a uma final a
funcionar com base em todas as três
controlam essas estruturas precisa
superar a funcionar podemos estar a
falar de casos com o temos uma treinada
determina o treinador
funcional nós queremos que exista a
passagem costumo pegar mas assim que
queremos que o clemente xi apaga zona da
sanção da parte institucional e
funcional esperancinha a maior grade
mudar uma maior vocação específica e
controlado e desta forma temos um
alimento funcional momento vai ao
encontro daquilo consumidor quer com o
nosso sol e são vários os exemplos de
tecnologias que nós podemos desenvolver
com base em engenharia conversa como uma
um argumento produtos que mais racional
temos que usar essa tecnologia é nada
tecnologia permitimos uma forma sua
bizarra compostos que são as ruas sem
água energia nem água e tenta
administrar não se fazer uma pessoa
consegue com isso nós conseguimos alguma
forma impessoal e sol em nas futuras nós
conseguimos todas as condições
atmosféricas em que conseguimos
ferramenta atualizá los em produtos
alimentares e conseguimos por exemplo
fazer água e tem uma área como na
particular ou uma forma homogênea 1 para
o inter nesta nesta imagem ou também
pensado em procurar a 13 em palmas pra
quem não sabe o amanhã 3
é um produto com o senhor sabor e aroma
a país devido ao ciclo aqui é extraído
se o colocássemos no palco e não esteja
com o paulo sapesp quase certeza que ia
reconstruída constatamos aqui matosinhos
acho que só vou continuar o caminho mais
complicado mas sui procurados e na
estrutura só micropartículas homem com
estruturas nós conseguimos proteger o
rosto
conseguimos esconder o ouro aqui é o que
ela está e podemos colocá lo em vão
consumir paulo pois temos a solução
três cantaram importante pra nossa
solidariedade se apresentar com um dos
compostos funcionais com maior área em
três partes e aumentaremos as incorporar
está esta é sua estrutura no qual outras
cidades são duras
a substituição de gorduras prejudiciais
provas mais faladas conseguimos assim
com alguns já estão lembrar os velhos
conseguimos assim simular a textura dos
alimentos substituído alguns compostos
podem ser prejudiciais e no caso das
gorduras está muito e vocês conhecem
aumentou sujas
as questões podem trazer para nossa para
a sessão ocorreu também do ponto de
vista tecnológico você consiga ter
algumas vantagens com essa estrutura nós
conseguimos modificar a forma como os
lado vai acumular a forma começou a
fumar aos cristais
nesse lado temos realmente modificar a
forma como uma margarina vai ter quando
colocarmos um tacho ou seja nós
conseguimos lugar também a forma ea
maneira com esses alimentos ou optar
quando nosso deus terá sim alimentos com
baixo teor de gordura
a operação da asae ter uma máquina
digital
ninguém acredita que não é que não é uma
matéria
isto porque conseguimos que aumentará os
cuidados na sua estrutura com figos das
propriedades industriais alemanha
consumidor está à espera de equipamentos
tecnológicos possíveis embalagens temos
na constituição já usados para aumentar
o tempo player a conservação dos
alimentos
uma forma natural permite procurar
compostos funcionais dessa forma
para o consumidor algumas dessas vias
com pontos mas também pode ser usado
como forma totalmente oferecê dor uma
embalagem falar orientar o seu primeiro
papel e aí o agulha
será que alguém tenha coragem de fazer
isso ou ter uma uma embalagem que temos
água e queremos conseguir embalagem com
água ou simplesmente ver essa água e
essa embalagem totalmente biodegradável
temos aqui sustentabilidade
juntamente com ela quando está a
aumentar
vimos mas volta agora ao jantar estamos
a ver um carro vinha mesmo tentadas
amanhã 1º
qualquer desvio só temos aqui alguns
exemplos da forma como é que nós podemos
desenvolver através do conhecimento da
estrutura daquilo que pretendemos alguns
alguns produtos que podem ser usados
quando se aumentar
nós estamos a falar de produtos
na minha opinião totalmente oferecer o
supremo está a pensar nos lados
luciano já se imaginava
ney franco - lado se uma uso muito
carinho e vocês sabem que o usuário além
de coco - lá eu estava em deficiência
já imaginaram que nunca imaginei também
nunca tive acesso ou simplesmente ter
uma água totalmente azul azul virou aos
compostos que são advogados e descaso da
micro-alga sabendo falar com certeza tem
orientação com microalgas os seus
benefícios passou realmente colocá la em
água e temos realmente uma azul com
participação de um produto totalmente
diferente da que eu estava
são vários os exemplos nós conseguimos
desenvolver que é possível desenvolver
através de processar estruturas conhecer
muito bem na funcionalidade queremos com
essa estrutura realmente engenharia
reversa
vamos facilitar a forma como
desenvolvemos que estamos a fazer
estruturas e elementos muito mais muito
mais
para o consumidor de forma realmente
aquilo que explicar mas uma coisa não
esqueça você e eu nós todos somos
consumidores somos nós temos claro se
diga aquilo que vamos comer nos
perguntar ao em casa
muito obrigado